we start today with President Joe
Biden's speech in Warsaw Poland this is
a speech that the president gave after
his visit to Ukraine this is a visit in
general and also in particular a speech
that has really exposed the worst of the
worst of the authoritarian right-wing in
the United States and one of the
fascinating things is we're going to
look at some clips here of this speech
that President Biden gave uh President
Biden focused in on a criticism of
autocrats and authoritarians
overtly he's talking about Vladimir
Putin but when you listen to the
criticism this would just as accurately
apply to the authoritarian autocratic
dictatorial wannabe magarite of the
United States Joe Biden was super strong
in this speech Let's Take a look at this
first section about autocracy and the
importance of opposing it anywhere that
we see it president cruises craving lust
for land and power will fail
and the Ukrainian people's love for
their country will prevail
democracies of the world will stand
guard over Freedom today tomorrow and
forever
so that's what is that's what's at stake
here freedom
that's the message I'd carry to Keith
yesterday
directly to the people of Ukraine
when president zielinski said he came to
the United States in December quote he
said this struggle
will Define the world and what our
children and grandchildren how they live
and then their children and
grandchildren
he wasn't only speaking about the
children and grandchildren of Ukraine
he was speaking about all of our
children and grandchildren yours and
mine
we're seeing again today with the people
of Poland and the people across Europe
saw for decades
appetites of the autocrac
cannot be appeased they must be opposed
autocrats only to understand one word no
no no no
you will not take my country
no you will not take my freedom no you
will not take my future
and I'll repeat tonight what I said last
year in the same place
a dictator
rebuilding an Empire will never be able
to ease the people's love of Liberty
brutality will never grind down the will
of the free
and Ukraine
Ukraine will never be a victory for
Russia never
so one of Biden's strongest speeches and
of course he doesn't write these he puts
his touch on them but he's not writing
these speeches but the message as much
as it here is designed for Putin it
could go for Orban
it could go for trump it could go for
the former Brazilian president jair
bolsonaro all of these autocrats have
this wannabe dictator streak and what is
stunning is that even though the right
has claimed a monopoly on freedom and
liberty in the United States for at this
point probably two decades uh it is
increasingly the right that wants to
restrict freedoms of all sorts of Kinds
what can we teach
what can we say
what can social media companies do what
can other private Industries do what can
people do in their bedroom what pronouns
can people choose to be called by right
increasingly it's the Democratic party
of which I am not a part as many of you
know I have no particular concern with
the Democratic party but this happens to
be a Democratic president
who is actually the one talking about
freedom and liberty in a more serious
way
um Joe Biden continued and said that uh
well let's just listen he addressed the
Ukrainian conflict specifically in the
United States together with our allies
and partners are going to continue to
have Ukraine's back as it defends itself
next year
I will host every member of NATO
for our 2024 Summit in the United States
together
will celebrate the 75th anniversary of
the strongest defensive Alliance in the
history of the world NATO
and
let there be no doubt
the commitment of the United States to
our NATO alliance and Article 5 is Rock
Solid
so there can be reasonable and spirited
debate as to how large should the
American contribution to Ukraine be how
long lasting should the commitment be
and is it fair or reasonable for the
United States to be
disproportionately supporting Ukraine in
comparison to other Allied countries all
of those are reasonable conversations
but what Joe Biden distilled clearly in
this speech is something that it's
shocking people still have to be
reminded of it and I know they do
because Vladimir Putin recently said in
his address something along the lines of
the U.S started this war Ukraine started
this war wasn't Russia who started the
war Russia started the war
this is a defensive situation for
Ukraine and Joe Biden doing a good job
of pointing that out
um and then going further in terms of
what the U.S and Western allies are
seeking and what they are not seeking so
tonight
I speak once more to the people of
Russia
the United States and the nations of
Europe do not seek to control or destroy
Russia
the West Was Not plotting to attack
Russia as Putin said today right and
millions of Russian citizens
we'll only want to live in peace with
their neighbors are not the enemy
this war is never a necessity
it's a tragedy
President Putin chose this war
every day the war continues is his
choice
it could end the war with the word
it's simple
if Russia stopped invading Ukraine it
would end the war
if you crane stop defending itself
against Russia would be the end of
Ukraine
that's why together we're making sure
Ukraine can defend itself yeah and again
it is stunning that this has to be
repeated you can still make the case
that despite it being a defensive
situation for Ukraine the US's
involvement should have limits that's a
perfectly reasonable conversation to
have I don't know of anyone on the left
who is saying that these are unlimited
blank checks for the end of time that is
not what I'm hearing anybody's saying if
somebody is saying that please let me
know but the context and the
circumstances in which this is happening
must be restated regularly because there
is a propaganda effort from Putin and
from others to pretend that the
circumstances are different let's next
talk about how this entire Ukraine visit
has broken the brains of many right
Wingers
one of our sponsors is zipx nicotine
toothpicks don't you think it's time you
stopped putting smoke and vape oils in
your lungs zippix toothpicks are a
convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zipx toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 with the
code pacman10 at checkout out just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below